virtual reality ist endlich zu uns nach
hause gekommen nachdem wir monate jahre
und vielleicht sogar jahrzehnte gewartet
haben kann man sich jetzt endlich eine
brille ins wohnzimmer holen um wirklich
in die digitale welt einzutauchen
augmented oder mixed reality erleben
gerade eine ähnlich erstaunliche
aufmerksamkeit und einen riesigen
aufschwung was mir aber auffällt ist
dass das fast alles irgendwie
entertainment ist games 360° filme oder
richtige filme alles ist erst einmal
spaß und unterhaltung klar
microsoft stellt sich mit der hugo lentz
auch eine zukunft der produktivität in
der mixed reality vor
aber bis wir dahin kommen ist es noch
ein weiter weg ich wollte jetzt
herausfinden wie wir heute schon virtual
reality nutzen können um zu lernen und
zu forschen
vor ein paar monaten im märz habe ich
die photonik akademie begleitet und
dabei nicht nur menschen aus der
forschung rund ums licht kennengelernt
sondern auch ein nobelpreisträger
interviewt das video dazu könnt ihr hier
finden aber einen menschen den ich dabei
auch kennengelernt habe war clemens
wagner
er arbeitet in der entwicklungsabteilung
von via magic einer firma die
simulatoren herstellt mixed reality
simulatoren und zwar zum ausbilden von
augenärzten also es geht darum es geht
um zu trainieren und es geht darum so zu
trainieren dass ich schon beim training
in der scheinbar echten welt bin das
heißt die simulatoren bemühen sich alles
zu tun damit ich das gefühl habe ich bin
jetzt wirklich an patienten ich
diagnostiziere den echten patienten und
ich operiere den echten patienten in
wirklichkeit sieht sich auf einer
maschine genau eine maschine die einen
täuschend echten patienten simuliert an
dem man alles ausprobieren kann
bei dem fehler keine schäden verursachen
können und das aller coolste ich durfte
den simulator auch ausprobieren so genau
das ist der effekt
man kann augen untersuchen und muss
dabei bestimmte stellen finden und auch
operieren um mit skalpell umgehen und
ich kann euch sagen es ist wirklich ein
mega cool effect obwohl man weiß dass
der kopf natürlich fake ist ist er
trotzdem irgendwie echt als würde
wirklich jemand da sitzen und seine
augen für mich auf machen also wirklich
komisch zu beschreiben aber woran liegt
das
das ist ein erstaunlicher effekt also da
gibt es glaube ich verschiedene sachen
die da rein spielen das eine ist eben
immersion also ich versuche alle
sinnesorgane die irgendwie beteiligt
sind an dem ganzen anzusprechen optik
visueller sehen unter umständen auch
akustik das piepen von der op maschine
dann interaktivität natürlich das was
ich tue hat nur mittelbaren effekt und
dann gibt es aber noch noch was ganz
anderes nämlich zum beispiel wenn ein
lehrer hinter mir steht und mir zuguckt
oder ich generell in irgend einer
schwierigen situation bin also wenn ich
gestresst bin von dem was ich da tun
muss dann vergesse ich auch sehr leicht
dass ich in der simulation bin also je
mehr ich involviert bin durch die
interaktivität desto leichter vergessen
dass das alles nur fake ist wieder
gesorgt
aber du siehst keine löcher aber
funktioniert das alles auch kann man nur
mit hilfe von virtual reality lernen wie
man echte augen operiert wie magic
liefert diese simulatoren in die ganze
welt in den usa lernen sogar über 80
prozent der angehenden augenärzte an
universitäten an diesen simulatoren
ich selber habe schon nach wenigen
minuten gemerkt wie ich mit licht und
lupe besser umgehen konnte um auch an
die schwierigen winkel der netzhaut zu
kommen aber am erstaunlichsten fand ich
klebe ins aussage selber als ich ihn
gefragt habe ob er sich zutrauen würde
selber eine schwierige augen-op
durchzuführen
obwohl er noch nie einen echten menschen
unter dem skalpell hatte darf nicht aber
das fade ist ein drama in meinem beruf
aber habe ich würde ich denke dass
solche simulatoren in der ausbildung die
zukunft sind für piloten gibt es das ja
schon lange und für andere berufe wird
es jetzt mit via vielleicht bald zur
normalität
schreibt mir nochmal unten in die
kommentare welche einsatzmöglichkeiten
euch dazu noch einfallen
der besuch bei die armee schickte auf
jeden fall eine geile erfahrung für mich
und ich möchte mich noch mal ganz
herzlich beim team dafür bedanken dass
ich dort ohne probleme drehen durfte und
dass ich selber einer augen-op
durchführen durfte vor zwei wochen bin
ich dann noch einmal in den süden
deutschlands gefahren
ich wurde von zeiss eingeladen und
konnte forschern und entwicklern aus der
wissenschaft meine fragen stellen unter
anderem auch michael trotz der mir
erklärt hat wie virtual reality
verwendet werden kann um große
datenmengen zu analysieren
das problem ist das heutige instrumente
wirklich gigabyte an daten produzieren
und ich muss einfach mich ich muss diese
daten in irgendeiner form eine menschen
zugänglich machen
wenn sie jetzt hier wirklich große
dreidimensionale datensätze haben von 3d
gedruckten teilen oder von zell
verbänden oder von irgendeinem gewebe
müssen sie versuchen das zu
visualisieren jetzt können sie das
machen sie schauen sich einfach
verschiedene schnitte an und überlegen
sich an welcher stelle ist jetzt was
oder sie bauen 3d modelle auf wenn sie
ein 3d modell sehen auf dem bildschirm
haben sie in der regel das problem dass
sie einfach nur die oberfläche sehen
dann können sie das jetzt ein stück weit
transparent machen dann können sie auch
hineingucken mit virtueller reality wie
hier in dieser applikation können sie
einfach hinein fliegen in verschiedenen
vergrößerung stufen wird der 3d
datensatz jetzt hier in echtzeit
gerendert sie können hinein fliegen und
sie können sich einfach ihr 3d objekt
angucken die wenn sie sich in diesem
objekt zu finden
das thema big data wird immer
interessanter wie macht man diese
unglaublich vielen daten die ständig
gesammelt produziert und geordnet werden
sichtbar
und was kann man mit diesen ganzen daten
eigentlich anfangen wird schon reality
erlaubt es forschern zum beispiel 3d
scans von objekten viel schneller zu
analysiert
als zum beispiel mit 2d bildern ob ich
den krebs im gewebe suche oder
eingeschlossene luft löcher in einer
metall schraube auch forscher können mit
einem xbox controller viel schneller
umher fliegen und sich orientieren als
2d scans schicht für schicht zu
durchsuchen
dafür wurden die controller ja auch
designed und das gaming und forschung
zusammen funktionieren können hat schon
2008 schuldet gezeigt ein computerspiel
bei dem man proteine falten muss um das
energie minimum zu erhalten
ein problem dass forscher schon seit
langem versuchen zu lösen und dass sie
kurzerhand an alle gamer weitergegeben
haben
und das mit erfolg 2011 fanden die gamer
zb ein protein das bei der aids
forschung geholfen hat ich bin auch hier
mega gespannt welche neuerungen noch auf
uns zukommen werden aber wissenschaft
auf eine intuitivere und damit auf eine
spaßige weise zu gestalten ist definitiv
etwas von dem ich mehr sehen will
und an dieser stelle auch vielen vielen
lieben dank ans eis für die tatkräftige
unterstützung
das hat mich wirklich mega gefreut dass
mir experten an die seite gestellt
wurden die meine fragen beantwortet
haben auch das war eine sehr coole
erfahrung vielen dank dafür
ansonsten bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt
was ihr zu diesem ganzen thema zu sagen
habt wo seht ihr noch einsatzorte von
virtual und augmented reality außerhalb
von unterhaltung schreibt sie wohnen in
die kommentare ich freue mich schon sehr
auf eure antworten ansonsten bis zum
nächsten mal
roger reinauer cedrick